[Musique]
notre ca ce soir diane bérard et robert
d'automne bonsoir mon frère robert qui
nous on ne fait un petit échange il ya
deux journées
cette semaine alors merci robert d'être
avec nous en ce mercredi soir
ce beau mercredi soir pierre fait
gribben donc se retire
robert d'abord tiens est ce que c'est la
chose à faire de la part du ministre
fait qu'ils veulent je crois que c'est
la chose à faire compte tenu des
circonstances la recommandation du
commissaire est quand même très clair ce
deal c'est un débat qui dure depuis très
longtemps à monsieur le fils tribune a
toujours un peu de démontrer de la
difficulté à s'adapter aux règles je me
suis en quelques semaines c'est pas
quelques jours après sa nomination il
veut dit il fait passer une situation
déjà zappé pour moi je vais me retirer
je pense que c'était pour le respect de
l'institution du rôle de la commissaire
je pense que c'était c'était la bonne
chose à faire mais ça a pris quatre
rapports quand même pour qu'il arrive
justement cette conclusion diane votre
commentaire là dessus et on était rendu
l'eau après quatre à part je pense que
comme monsieur guaino 10 pour le bien du
gouvernement un gouvernement dans lequel
ils croient je pense que c'est pétain
qui sert fatigue
monsieur legault a dit y a pas de
conflit d'intérêts ya apparence de
conflit d'intérêts
il n'y a pas de conflit d'intérêts
pierre fête des boeufs nés honnête c'est
un homme de grand calibre mais pas de
conflit d'intérêts
robert de tenait ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça premièrement faut dire
que je pense pas que personne qui
remettent en question l'honnêteté puis
le rapport ne remet pas en question
l'honnêteté la compétence de mr facebook
mais sur facebook buzz ne respecte pas
les conditions du code d'éthique
ouais et inévitablement you apparence de
conflit d'intérêts
je me suis à l'automne dernier on en
avait discuté l'histoire de la part aux
conflits d'intérêts c'est toujours une
notion qui est difficile à comprendre
même dans des entreprises gétules
expliqué à plusieurs reprises
donc je pense que c'est là que le bât
blesse puis monsieur fils guy bono
fesquet baisse médiane je pense que
c'est assez clair vous êtes ministre
vous êtes au conseil exécutif
vous ne pouvez pas avoir des intérêts
dans une entreprise qui de surcroît fait
affaire avec le gouvernement un caddie
mère vision il y avait des prêts et dans
le cas de whitehorse et une entreprise
dans lequel un investissement québec
investit qu'est ce que monsieur fait
tiquer bonne ne comprenait pas jusqu'à
ce matin
d'abord c'est un peu agaçant l'habitude
que le premier ministre a pris de
ramener ça sur l'honnêteté de monsieur
physique est bonne sur les conflits
d'intérêts et quand il dit techniquement
il répond pas aux codes était tel qu'il
est écrit maintenant c'est simple ils
répondent pas aux cours d'éthique taux
courts donc de mettre l'accent sur le
conflit d'intérêts sur l'honnêteté c'est
tenir le projecteur loin d'une simple
réalité c'est qu'il ya un code d'éthique
depuis 2019
ils répondent pas au code d'éthique ça a
été rappelé à plusieurs reprises donc ça
sert à rien de mettre le projecteur
ailleurs cela personne ne remet en
question notre cour j'ai pas entendu
d'évidence on dit que monsieur messier
p-dg et bunny maloney touba conflit
d'intérêts mais ils ne respectent pas le
code d'éthique et comme dit robert il
semblerait que depuis une buse peu
difficile pour me suis fait des bonnes
de suivre à lire et qui dit qu'il ne
peut pas vendre ses actifs ses intérêts
dans deux entreprises
sinon il aurait perdu trop d'argent est
ce que c'est une défense acceptable
robert dutton bain et cie voudrais
monsieur tribune a parlé d'un million de
dollars c'est quand même une somme
importante mais les règles sont là et
dans le passé il ya eu d'autres
personnes du milieu des affaires qui
sont allés en politique on parle de
monsieur arx pierre arcand je pense que
mentionné qu'ils avaient perdu d'argent
on sait que ça a été aussi difficile
pour monsieur péladeau il ya eu pas le
marché donc il ya eu d'autres gens ils
se sont adaptés
alors je peux comprendre que la décision
d'aller la politique a été très rapide
je prends pas un peu les événements pour
plusieurs raisons donc je pense que pas
eu le temps de réaliser qu'il y avait
des gestes à poser
puis il ya peu choix s'il faut les poser
vos pierre arcand les opposer il a vendu
à perte ses actifs pourraient être en
politique pour être ministre françois
legault s'est auto site est aujourd'hui
en disant j'ai tous transformés en
obligations gouvernementales du québec
il ya des gens qui ont ri de moi mais au
moins monsieur legault s'est donné la
possibilité d'avoir tout lé
liberté de servir le public n'en d'être
dans service public
je veux d'ailleurs vous faire entendre
tout de suite le premier ministre le
groupe aujourd'hui si on va voir des
gens compétents pour négatif des gens
d'affaires
c'est mieux d'avoir des gens qui ont de
l'expérience dans nombre d enfants puis
les gens dans le monde des affaires la
plupart ont des placements les
entreprises qu'elle sort de mon nom vu
dans nos gouvernements pour s'occuper
d'économie
la question est lancée par le premier
ministre john key ce que vous en pensez
c'est pas la bonne question la question
qu'il faut se poser c'est quelle
proportion de gens d'affaires est ce
qu'on a besoin parmi des élus pour
atteindre la société qu'on veut à moyen
et à long terme et c'est une question
d'équilibré
on n'est plus dans les années 80 je
pense je pense que le raisonnement de
monsieur le goût d'un raisonnement les
années 80 je pense que la réalité de
l'économie beaucoup trop complexe pour
s'en remettre uniquement à des gens
d'affaires pour prendre décision dans
les années 80 la crise climatique c'est
une vue de l'esprit
les années galite et c'est quelque chose
qui suivait dans les pays du sud donc à
quelque part il faut comprendre que oui
les gens d'en face
mercer pour l'économie mais y'a pas que
les gens d'affaires ici on regarde le
profil des ministres de l'économie qu'on
a eu par le passé ce n'était pas juste
des gens d'affaires à ce que je sache
robert vous en pensez quoi je peux plus
que comme dit andy bausch d'accord avec
quelqu'un qu'on vernement savons
multitude de personnes avec des des
compétences différentes
maintenant pour moi je vois pas
nécessairement le problème comme chez
tantôt on en a eu des gens du milieu des
affaires et qui se sont adaptés donc
c'est pas au code d'éthique à s'adapter
on remarquer que peut-être des
corrections en faire je voyais que dans
le code éthique on demande 60 jours pour
se débarrasser de ou de vendre des
actions d'entreprises privées c'est pour
beaucoup
effectivement c'est s'est pas beaucoup
de ce fait de la c3 un oui donc est-ce
que ça doit 3 1 je pense pas non plus
donc
mais pour moi c'est pas la question je
pense qu'il ya des gens d'affaires qui
sont allés dans le passé il ya des gens
d'affaires yvon lapointe c'est que
gerald s'il ya un beau projet une vision
inspirante sur des valeurs solides
autour d'eux
roger la 6e des règles d'éthique
sérieuse et un projet rassembleur
les gens d'affaires comprendre les
moyens nécessaires pour un an politiques
occupent un beau cri du coeur je vous
amène sur air canada
aujourd'hui on va terminer là tu
peut-être une question aux deux sur air
canada qui dit que les programmes de
rémunération variable comme la prime de
motivation covin là on parle de 10
millions de dollars qui a été versées à
des dirigeants et des cadres d'air
canada
c'est une forme normale de
reconnaissance à l'endroit d'un groupe
limité pour leurs efforts diane votre
commentaire reçu mon commentaire c'est
que ça fait plusieurs années que les ca
des grandes sociétés sont déconnectés de
la réalité nous l'ont prouvé à maintes
reprises
la preuve c'est la prime ou ladislau
différentiel entre le salaire du pdg le
salaire médian des employés on parle au
canada de 237 fois donc c'est sûr que
les excès les abus pour accorder des
rémunérations sont que quand c'est a dit
oui c'est normal qu'on accorde mais
c'est très difficile de le croire parce
que les siens sont devenus déconnecter
complètement quand il s'agit de la
rémunération des pdg les nôtres nous
notre ca est connecté bien sûr robert
vous en pensez quoi vous j'entends sont
plus que dix agents tos que tu en dis
mais aussi c'est une question d'argent
est-ce que vous avez regardé combien se
paie les membres du conseil
d'administration d'air canada cancer au
dessus de 200 mille dollars par année
ok puis au dd des actions des options
d'actions donc ça peut prendre encore
plus va c'est pas uniquement dans la
rénumération des caps qui sont parfois
est très exagéré mais si aussi leur
propre édition dans un ordre monde et
moi je trouve ça très inacceptable ce
qu'ils ont fait à l'égard des employés
de tous les employés qui sont en chômage
à l'égard de la population si nous comme
canadien cpc 5 5 milliards de dollars
qu'on a donnée moi je trouve que c'est
indécent sera encore lost c'est un
manque d'éthique vraiment c est indécent
c'est irrespectueux
moi je sais pas comment les actionnaires
le conseil d'administration d'as en
direction des banlieues
afin de joueurs probablement que
personnes vont dire un mot encore parce
que ça fait partie de la règle mais
j'appelle ça du bourg gaullisme
'corporate' du bourgogne a commencé
comme des bougon oui mais qu'au repos
lundi
alors c'est tout moment se dessine gagne
de bourgon bon je peux réaliser ce que
j'adore ça les employés ont perdu leur
emploi
les actionnaires ont perdu de l'argent
les contribuables canadiens ont
contribué à air canada madame rien dit
je suis déçu c'est inapproprié diane en
termine avec vous que doit faire le
gouvernement fédéral à prendre de cette
énorme erreur
le gouvernement a dit à partir du moment
donné où on vous fait le prêt vous devez
plafonner les salaires de la direction
mais c'était sans compter que le
capitalisme est comme une rivière le
détournant quelque part qui colla ya
donc comment ils n'ont pas pensé ou il
fallait qu'ils savaient déjà qu'ils
avaient des bonis qui était accordé
alors si on sera jamais le fond de
l'histoire mais apprendre de ça quand il
subventionne une entreprise il ya des
choses qui sont rétroactives aussi puis
consultables la fin d'année où on
accorde des bonis faut se poser des
questions robert d'automne merci d'avoir
été là mercredi soir diane bérard merci
rico pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit